these were perfect calls these were
calls where you're questioning the
validity
and the safety of Elections and it's a
disgrace that they're allowed to even
think about it but not one person
protested until long after that call
right and if there was something wrong
with that call I am not a stupid person
number one I'm an honest person so I
wouldn't do it anyway but when people
are on the opponent Trump would know
whether there was anything right or
wrong whether there was anything wrong
with the call that's not true Trump
doesn't know anything and Trump would
never lie about the call that's not true
Trump lies all the time